hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreign ago today we have
some interesting info to talk about from
the Vorta girl reveal stream we're gonna
be looking at some black prior stuff so
as always like to me if you do enjoy
subscribe for free new I covered the
informational site or foreigner that
being balanced changes here updates
patch notes and leaks
that's good started with today's video
so first up we have the black prior
moveset and some gameplay real quick
this is what the black prior looks like
in-game looks real sick his GP doesn't
actually push them like warlord he
knocks them over kind of like conker so
that's a good thing to know
he has a full block move called bulwark
stance it has two moves in it this one
is the counter where you flip the
opponent over them and throw an
unblockable heavy which is guaranteed
you don't even need to press the heavy
button it does it for you and you can
even counter demons embrace with it just
like normal full blocks you cannot guard
break or counter guard break in this
move so that's the one weakness the one
thing though about this counter move is
that it's very similar to a parry so
instead of throwing it out randomly and
hooking them you have to play it off as
if you're trying to parry but you're
instead of pressing the light attack
button instead of the heavy attack
button black power also has two bashes
as if that wasn't obvious enough the
first one is from neutral wishes I dash
forward guard break it's pretty small in
terms of range so I highly doubt this is
going to be very useful but if connected
you can follow over they like finisher
you can also do a light into shield into
light as well as shown on screen so a
pretty decent combo coming from that the
other is a heavy feint into shield bash
very similar to conch bash and this one
I would say is a lot more useful all you
have to do is feint the heavy button and
go right into a guard break and after
that of course you can of course fall
with a light attack very similar to the
other bash he also has a dodge forward
heavy which is a little bit of a poke
move and this can also be a crushing
counter move as well so that's very
useful if you want to use that all of
his chains are to hit attacks the light
light light heavy heavy light all that
it's on an infinite combo but you can do
any type of two combinations in a row
and that will be a chain they also
showed a little bit of a description of
the move set and black prior has
superior block on all of his live
attacks and all of the heavy finishers
are undoubtable which is that blue smoke
you see on the move
so if a character does light and then
heavy that last heavy will be an
undoubtable so have to be wary about
that one he also has a zone and it is
actually unblockable but this does not
do any damage only stamina damage after
you connect you can fall with the
guaranteed light attacks you can kind of
count that his damage but you don't
actually have to do the light attack and
does it also looks like that the zone
does not wall splat I'm wondering if the
they're bashes do that as well if any of
these moves don't wall spot I'm gonna be
interested to see how this characters
gonna play out in the real game they
also showed off a bit of his feet his
tier two feet is that you can heal in
ball mark stance so if you're a little
bit of health pop down on the deer down
on your little right stick or whatever
you happen to be playing on you'll be
healing in ball mark stance his Tier
three feet is removing all the shield
from the opponent that you lock onto and
this works in revenge as well so you as
soon as someone pops revenge you can get
rid of that shield then waste their time
his tier one is giving a teammate is
shield while also losing health so
that's a little bit of a give and take
so that could be pretty useful in a four
view four and his tier four feet is a
pulsing shield buff so if you pop a
shield and a teammate loses it
immediately you can give it back to them
because this is a pulsing AoE it goes I
believe three times so you can get a lot
of shield back and it's a full and tiger
shield which is really nice overall I
think black Pryor is gonna be very
useful I thought I feel like he's gonna
be very nice in 44 is maybe not so much
in duels but these feats are telling me
otherwise that he's gonna be very good
in the four before game moves and just
to end I'm gonna show off a little bit
of the executions they showed throughout
the game play and with that let's
continue on with the rest of the video
for real quick let's talk about Orochi
and not just the Roachy from the game
but project Orochi a colo than company
that makes japanese style clothing and
who is the sponsor of today's video
they got inspiration from foreigner for
example orochi's in the name of the
company project Orochi they have a
riptide t in the shop named after a row
cheese move Riptide strike vipers
retreat is also a t-shirt in the shop
and it's a nod to Nobu she's back step
move vipers retreat there's a secure
reference on the shinobi tea where it
says Orochi shadows die twice where the
title of the game is actually secured Oh
shadows died twice and the two-tone
hoodies in the shop are actually colors
from the og mythic outfits a mere one
that you'll see on screen now and my
personal favorite one at which this is
the one I'm gonna be getting is the
torah' tiger hoodie which looks
absolutely amazing it has the word of
Roachy on the front as a bonus you can
use the discount code light spam for 10%
off the entire order I will leave that
down in the description thank your
project to wrote you for sponsoring the
video and let's continue on with the
news for today next up is black prior
armor the armor is gonna be split up
into two sections leather and metal
that's what they said
now I'm not entirely sure if the
little-little leather is going to be
coming first and then the metal
afterwards or if it's just kind of a mix
of both throughout the ranks but I'm
pretty sure at the highest rank you can
achieve all of them but for example this
is the look at some of the leather armor
do you have some long beards a lot more
scars they said this some of the
beginner sets and there's also the
sculpt piece which I do believe is part
of the leather set looks really nice I'm
definitely rockin the skull helmet 100%
and then here is also a picture of some
of the metal there's lots of metal and
inner details in here making this look
really incredible although I do like I
said prefer the skull mask I definitely
like the metal helmets a lot more I said
this in my previous here this gives me
more of a Diablo vibe so I'm definitely
gonna be wearing a lots of his arm or
trying to interchange mostly probably in
the metal section because I prefer metal
more than leather but that's just up to
personal preference and here are some of
the weapons these are more of an
evolution of the weapons the beginning
ones that I'm showing on screen are
gonna be the ones you're gonna be
getting in the very beginning with the
first one being his default one then
going further and further into more
fantasy looking weapons ones with skulls
and faces and dragons and snakes and
skeletons and all this type of [ __ ] big
fantasy looking weapons it's definitely
gonna be very excited to get to the
highest rank possible which is about
seven or eight so I can get that max
tier armor and weapons because I'm
definitely gonna be rockin that skeleton
dragon looking thing on one of those
shields so
let me know you guys think about these
types of weapons and armor let me know
what you guys think about this I think
these are some of the coolest looking
things we've had for character in a long
time afterwards this showed the new map
harbor for season 9 this is a really
cool looking map and it's available in
duel brawl skirmish elimination and
everyone's favorite game mode Dominion
and it's also a pretty small map like I
stated in my past videos I like that
it's small because it will have a lot of
close engagements and unending fights
it's really nice to see according to the
devs this is according to the lore of
the map there is a it is basically a
night map that was rated by the Vikings
but hence why there's so many Viking
ships everywhere and it looks really
cool it's like a war-torn battle scene
and the big middle ship is where point B
is going to be and on top of that
there's actually going to be a second
floor there you go via a ladder and
there's actually two ziplines ones that
one that goes to C and one that goes to
a when you're up there online for fast
easy access to a certain point so if
your team holds the B point you
basically kind of control most of the
map or can get to other points back very
quickly if they happen to take a C or an
8 point during the Dominion match next
up we have the hero improvements may
have shougo key peacekeeper and warlord
first up is shougo key and they want to
make him be very successful with mix-ups
and also have the trading potential very
similar to Highlander first up the
passive hyper armor is now gone and that
means that when he when you know when he
loses his hyper armor he takes more
damage that is also gone he has a but
his light heavy endzone attack now have
hyper armor just on the individual moves
not just him in general his health is
not 140 instead of 160 his heavy cannot
be fainted at different points like ward
and shoulder bash you can also saw faint
be heavy into a demon's embrace once
again using the heavy button his own
attack is not a quick wipe as shown it's
a one hit not a two hit anymore so
that's pretty nice to see his head book
can now be thrown after a zone a heavy
end a light in its unblockable you don't
actually have to connect the move you
can with the light attack and go right
into a headbutt demons embrace is now
our move from neutral stance but it's
still in the game you can only do demons
embrace after a guard break throw and
even after a headbutt no more one shot
and kill on the demons embrace now it
does 25 damage and he owes you 425
health
you can also regain full stamina from
demons Bray's very similar to shamans
bite he can also be canceled out and
move very similar to shamans play as
well so make sure your teammates do not
hit you when you do the move his heavy
finishers are now unblockable and of
course can be fainted in just
print attack is now from the top stance
and can be linked into head butts and
heavy finishers and as well lastly the
demon ball is now going to be a little
bit faster or the golf swing if you call
it that and lawd bringer won't be
getting a rework but it's not looking
like anytime soon the devs did say that
it's currently in production right now
so most likely not season 9 may be in
season 10 sorry too while you'll all
bring remains out there we'll get them
next time
next up is peacekeeper on warlord
remember these are just changes not
full-on rework so this list is gonna be
a little bit small so keep up
peacekeeper cannot do a heavy on a GB
and specifics you can actually do the
top heavy top openers are now slower but
is now your light parry punish and I
believe does 23 damage stamina on some
moves are a little bit lower which is
nice making her have a lot more stamina
in the fight and her damage is also
slightly buffed on most moves slightly
by about two or three damage extra
warlord is the last of the changes and
his out of lock move hits a lot farther
into the movement you can value a lot
easier he has a couple new chains and on
superior blocks it is now unblockable
and does a lot more damage as shown on
screens as it is a unblockable move
Woolard zone is now undoubtable and his
full block has changed when you pop out
of it you get actually you gain your
stamina a lot quicker before after you
would come out of full block you would
have to wait 3 or 4 seconds for you to
regain stamina now as soon as you come
out a full block you're regaining
stamina so it's a lot quicker and you
lose a lot less stamina when going into
full walk so a lot of stamina region for
that character let me know your thoughts
on these changes in the comments below I
hope this really helps you go key and
not be bottom tier but we'll have to see
when the game actually launches and that
guys that's gonna be the end of the VA I
hope you guys did enjoy I didn't show
the season 9 executions cuz I already
made a video earlier this morning at
around 8 in the morning so you can see
my past videos you can go check that
it'll be at the end of this video so
don't worry about that I mean their
thoughts on the rework of shougo key the
patch for warlord and peacekeeper the
black prior stuff into Harbor mouth
anything that was talked about none of
you let me know what you guys think
about all that in the comments down
below but that like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe before new I cover the
informational side of 400 that being
balanced changes your updates
passionates and leaks without my two
most recent videos will be on screen if
you guys do want to check that out when
I guys hope ever yesterday thank for
watching the video peace out enjoy the
gameplay